hi my name is Elena hi my name's will  and our office is located in Ireland we  are auditors in the area of health and  food safety  our job is unique it allows us to see on  the spot if and how our high you  standards are met by the countries  outside and inside the EU and through  this we come to Butte to the protection  of European consumers working  internationally we cover a range of  interesting topics including food and  feed safety animal and plant health  medical devices and more are you a team  player looking for a challenging role in  health and food safety then it's you we  are looking for apply now if you liked  this video please like share and  subscribe to our Channel